So the answer is we don't need 20 multiplications; we only need 4.
And the property we're taking advantage of is that X to the 2A is equal to X to the A squared.
That means we can break 2 to the 20 down into parts--
it's equal to 2 to the 10th squared
which is equal to 2 to the 5 squared squared
which is equal to--now 2 to the 5 is not divisible by 2--
so that's equal to 2 to the 4 times 2 squared and squared.
And so the number of multiplications--
well what we're computing is each square involves a multiplication--
so there's 1 multiplication there, there's 1 multiplication there,
there's 1 multiplication there, and there's 1 multiplication there--
so 4 total multiplications.
So this does not scale exponentially in the size of the power.
So this means computing A to the N power requires
on the order of log N multiplications.
In terms of the size of N, that means it's linear
in terms of the number of bits needed to represent the power.